es el último proyecto de ley del
gobierno francés dedicado al medio
ambiente este lunes la asamblea nacional
inicia el examen del proyecto de ley de
clima y resiliencia el espíritu del
proyecto de ley de clima y resiliencia
es llevar la ecología a la vida
cotidiana de los franceses para darles
los medios para poder ser ambientalistas
se supone que la ley retoma las 149
propuestas hechas por la convención
sobre el clima pero al final solo se
seleccionaron 10 de ellas además es un
texto considerado insuficiente por el
consejo superior del clima así como por
un centenar de organizaciones el texto
nos permite reducir nuestras emisiones
de gases de efecto invernadero en un 40
por ciento para 2030 y menos aún
alcanzar el nuevo objetivo europeo de
reducción del 55 por ciento mientras que
la ciencia recomienda una reducción del
65% las medidas a incluir en el proyecto
de ley son la rehabilitación térmica de
los edificios la regulación de la
publicidad de productos contaminantes un
menú vegetariano obligatorio en
restaurantes para el público en general
y la limitación estricta de vuelos
domésticos
enmiendas fueron presentadas por los
diputados para el examen del proyecto de
ley que se llevará a cabo durante tres
semanas un tiempo que los ambientalistas
consideran demasiado corto dada la
emergencia climática